tu aimais la beauté if on ne sait pas
d'où vient un coup un instinct personne
ne vous l'apprends ce jour là tu as
rencontré la gloire
et depuis elle et toi ne vous êtes plus
quittés
avec mes robes avec mes descentes gsm
exprimer mais sûrement langage fait
mourir le talent tu là le reste je m'en
occupe ces quatre collections par an on
sait pas qui va les faire peut-être j'en
peux plus je suis épuisé mais tout ça
qui l'a voulu il veut regardez moi tu
veux vivre tu veux mourir parce que si
tu veux mourir moi je peux rien faire
pour toi
tu peux pas isolé if comme ça c'est
juste un tour de parts avant tout on va
dire que je suis un tyran
un mode scène un art majeur bon ce n'est
pas un art du tout mais pour la faire
comme tu le fais toi il faut être un
artiste
il était un génie 10
sans toi y aurait rien eu
fera t on
satan dit allemand
je pouvais que les décevoir
quand on est mené en danger à ses
cinquièmes palais